everything must be in fine balance
that's what I mean by sustainability to
me it is not just the environment the
survival of not just the parent planet
but also society and at the heart of
that is the need to do business with
responsibility with with ethics
my name is Nick passaglia put first and
foremost an entrepreneur but my passion
really is in education I teach at
setting graduate institute one of the
top international business schools in
bangkok thailand i teach in the area of
sustainability
a lot of people say this is the Asian
century and perhaps with 2015 with the
new Association of Southeast Asian
nation Economic Community are seein
Southeast Asia will become a pact
similar to European Union but hopefully
without all the flaws that will have a
huge impact in our region
it's a region of lots of resources lots
of culture lots to offer the rest of the
world
Myanmar is so rich in natural resources
there is a danger of the country being
pillaged I think the international
community does no better their consumers
are demanding responsible practices
demanding that they the welfare of the
workers through their whole supply chain
whether it's in China in but in Myanmar
or in their own country is of an
acceptable standard that is something
that one cannot always be confident in
but that seems to be the trend a lot of
large companies have had to change and
improve their practices based on
consumer demands with with free media
when companies cut corners when
companies act irresponsibly they are
exposed
so there is hope there is excitement
there is a sense of of wanting to do
more learn more experience more and most
importantly contribute towards the
betterment of their own country their
own society in their own people
you